the news of amari's death has devastated
our entire community dozens gathering at
the emerald suites this evening to show
support
and honor his life organizers also want
to stop something like this
from ever happening to another child
sasha loft is continuing our team
coverage tonight with more on their
message
brian you can really feel the sadness
and shock through every
single piece of that memorial dozens of
balloons candles and messages were there
all to show baby amari he was loved
a community comes together to grieve for
amari nicholson
you can't think you know just somebody
could hurt
a child you know an innocent child like
that
the two-year-old's death has shaken our
entire city
so dozens attended this vigil wednesday
to show their support
we brought candles and felt like we had
to do our part to try to get the rest of
the community out
and make sure others speak up for
children in similar situations
if you see it i know that it might not
be something you want to do
but it's something that you need to do
it's something that you need to do
because if not
this is where we are this is the outcome
those who organized the event didn't
know the toddler
but hope their presence shows anyone who
loved him
that all these people are behind them as
a community
i think las vegas has become more united
and we're here to support you know we're
here to
to just be together and above anything
else
every balloon flower and message left
is for amari thank you all for coming he
may be gone
but las vegas will never forget him i'm
sorry baby boy
and i hope you are resting very easy
and very much at peace now if you know
of a child in an abusive situation you
can call police or child protective
services to report it
using the number you see on your screen
here 702 399
we also have links to other resources on
our website
8newsnow.com